[Music]
hello everyone and a warm welcome in
joining us for the president design
award first ever webinar in the
education and career series the good the
bad and the ugly of a visual
communications career
i'm patreon from the design singapore
council and your mc for today
the president's design award or pda for
short is singapore's highest accolade
for designers and designs across all
disciplines
organized by the design singapore
council and the urban redevelopment
authority this is the 13th cycle of the
award
our latest crowd of 11 recipients were
awarded on 30th june this year
a couple of house rules just to keep
today's session running as smoothly as
possible firstly please be informed that
this webinar will be recorded and that
your microphones will be muted
throughout the session
you are most welcome to submit questions
through the zoom q a function and the
speakers will address them during the q
a segment
should you encounter any technical
issues please ping our technical team
through the zoom chat function
in this very first edition of the pda
education and career series students and
fresh graduates interested in a career
in design will have an up close and
personal opportunity to dialogue with
the recipients of singapore's highest
design accolade
what is the progression of a career in
design like how is the design profession
transforming in response to evolving
trends and what are some of the greatest
struggles and triumphs in their journey
and what advice do they have for young
designers
these are just some of the many
questions that our panel speakers will
be tackling today
it is now my pleasure to introduce the
recipients on our panel
miss kelly chain creative director of
the press room and pda 2020 designer of
the year
ms arjuna stalin creative director of
kinetic singapore and pda 2020 design of
the year for the not so convenient store
mrs steve lawler co-founder and head of
creative of ir and pda 2020 design of
the year for ir
mr larry pay founder and creative
director and larry and pda 2014 designer
of the year larry was also a member of
the pda 2020 design jury panel
our moderator for today is mr felix lee
co-founder and ceo of the global
mentorship platform amazing design
people adp list which allows people to
book and meet mentors from around the
world
now before we begin the session we'd
like to get to know a little bit more
about you on the poll that we just
launched on the screen
please share with us which design
disciplines you are from
so there will be a total of 10
options you can choose multiple options
that are applicable to you
and if you select other design
disciplines or even other non-design
disciplines please feel free to share
with us in the zoom chat function
okay visual communication is winning
get the majority vote just allow a
couple more seconds to allow the
responses to come streaming in
okay so nice to see that most of you are
from the visual communications
discipline followed by architecture
advertising and design research and
design strategy thank you so much for
your participation
we now jump straight into the sharing
biospeakers
without further ado let's welcome our
first speaker kelly ching trained as an
architect kelly is the founder and
creative director of the press room a
publishing and design consultancy with
projects that include publications
brands exhibitions documentaries and
even stage and film set design
an active educator and a passionate
champion of design over a two decade
career she has served as adjunct
lecturer in singapore universities and
has set on international design judging
panels including red dot awards nagoya
nagoya doe design for asia award
creative circle award and the james
tyson award kelly over to you please
thank you patient
okay i'm going to start to share my
screen first
and uh everybody see my screen
yes okay good okay okay so uh hi guys
for for those who uh have never
encountered the press room or myself
we are the press room is a
interdisciplinary design studio so we do
a variety of different genres of design
from graphic to spatial to digital to
multimedia so it's a really quite a
mixed bag of things that we do here
and so i would like to start my talk
today by
sharing about
how or why i got into design
um for me i believe it is uh both nature
and nurture
since young i love to draw
and i will draw anywhere i draw on the
wall draw on my day draw everywhere
until my mom gave up so at four years
old she uh she checked me into a
painting school i started drawing with
crayon and i continued throughout uh
till my uh to secondary school uh so
mastering different uh forms of medium
in in drawing
um i think since young i always am
attracted to to something beautiful so i
i have the tendency to also want to
create you know sort of my own
uh form of beauty uh i didn't know what
design meant then uh all i knew was that
uh i want to i thought that i want to be
an artist really
but in secondary school i actually
picked up uh photography which which i
fell in love with so uh i started to
kind of venture into different forms of
creativity that could help me to
achieve um in my creation of uh beauty
so i think if someone naturally has an
interest
then you will find your own ways uh to
kind of get this passion uh to be
nurtured into something so uh these are
some of my works i did as a teenager so
growing up in secondary school um i
always volunteer myself you know they
say oh that's what i said i'll do that
with prior oh uh a poster i'll do it
i'll do anything it's all free but i
love to do it i just want to do it i
just want uh my design to be appreciated
by by everyone i think there is a sense
of
satisfaction and reward that is
unexplainable is really beyond what
money can buy so even as a teenager i
will cease every single opportunity uh
just you know for that uh 15 minutes of
fame so i was a big fan of andy wahl as
you can see i even painted him for one
of my poster design for university so
growing up there was a indie music
magazine called big o the older folks
here will know the younger ones probably
have not heard of it but it was then
the only music magazine actually today
also still right because there's no
music magazine in singapore but i'm very
very indeed very raw and um i
volunteered myself there uh they they
have no budget so i did everything for
free i took photos uh i did paintings
for them all these other some of the
covers that i did which led me to doing
uh my very first commercial work which
you can see there the octolus cd cover i
think offers just released their third
and latest album but uh the first one
was done by me and during that time i
didn't know how to use there was no in
desire there was a there was only page
maker uh which i i didn't have access to
because in the in the late 80s early 90s
having a mac is very very expensive so
your parents won't buy for you so i use
my own painting methods and to to kind
of simulate the screen effect i actually
photo set
different layers of imagery partial
images onto uh photostatic films you
know then i kind of like manually stitch
everything together and you get this uh
image there on the cover the oculus it's
actually a portrait of elvis as a as a
boy because it's called teenage eight so
it was also the first time i attempted
to do something conceptual and i got
quite addicted to it that was only when
i think i did that when i was 17 18
years old around some of your age now
um so yeah so i think growing up um i i
always uh i always try to find
opportunities for me to do something
creative and it was never about money
you know it was really uh just to
be able to do uh what i love you know
and to be appreciated
so this uh journey uh led me to um
to architecture school uh which was
because in the 90s uh unlike you guys
now who are very very fortunate there
are a variety of design schools
available for your choice in singapore
now but in the early 90s uh in fact i
was late 80s
if you want to go to uh do anything
you want to do a design degree
your choice is really quite limited to
only architecture at the national
university that's assuming if your
parents have no money to send you abroad
so yeah i went to architecture school
and after i graduated
six years
i still very much knew that my first
love is in graphic in creating graphic
in writing in taking photos and all that
so after a short sling uh in
architecture
and then a long travel of a year
kind of like searching my soul
i came back to singapore and in 1999 uh
i i decided to uh
make my own dream come true
so all along uh i always feel that uh
i'm a huge fan of like different indie
magazines and cool magazines and all
that uh so growing up i look at the face
i look at uh you know bikini i look at
ray gun and you know the usual staple of
indie magazines in the 80s and 90s and
and that dream
has always been in me that one day i
want to start my own
magazine
because it combines all my passion which
is writing photography
graphic design typography things like
that so in 1999 i um
i gathered my gaps and courage and
i just blindly started my own publishing
firm
and published
this magazine called ish
the tagline is called fragments of an
urban skate which is why i call it ish
because each in itself is always a
fragment of a word so the idea is to
really capture all aspects of
of the city because to me uh every
everything in life its design you know
everything uh we need design for
everything so it really is the fragments
of that urban scape uh this magazine was
uh launched uh at the before the
internet days and then it went into the
beginning of internet days so we were
quite lucky you know so sometimes people
said timing is everything so during that
time because there was no internet so
our magazine was uh was quite a hit you
know
and and i would say that really
looking back now i i really have to
thank this magazine because it has
really uh
allowed me to connect with the industry
not just singapore also uh also abroad
the global design industry in uh in a
very uh
broad way and up to today a lot of the
friends that i made through this
magazine
are still my friends today
and uh i forgot to mention why i also
was very keen to start this magazine
because
as i said earlier as a teenager i have
no platforms to showcase my passion you
know i want to create i'll take photos
even for free also no place to go you
know that's how sad it was so i want
each magazine to be a magazine that you
know young creatives like me have a
place to showcase their talent have a
place to you know we can jam together uh
everybody can contribute what they want
can contribute photography can commit
writing whatever you see so that was
really the vision of the magazine also
to propel the singapore brand to provide
a platform for singapore designers like
myself to to kind of shine and share our
works with the world
so i did ish for 10 years 1999 to 2009
and then in 2009 i started uh the
classroom
so
guys i think maybe many of you might
wonder if you should start your own
studio if you should work for someone or
whatever actually nothing is
wrong you know it's it's really up to
you
um but my advice to you is that work
somewhere for a few years first you know
learn your ropes first um and
when you're ready then start don't be in
a hurry to start because it is not not
easy running a studio you know you you
have bills to pay you you have stuff to
pay you need to look for clients and
there's actually a lot of nitty-gritty
things that you have to worry about
every single day so if my running a
studio uh might not be for everyone
uh hence i urge you guys to think
carefully uh before you start your own
design studio because
don't start for the wrong reasons don't
start because you think that you can
make a lot of money or whatever you know
um
you you need to have a higher aspiration
you see so i think for me it was quite
clear why i want to start my own studio
because since a kid since the teenage
and all that my passion is to create
beautiful things for people to enjoy you
know like a chef who cooks something
nice you want people to eat it taste it
and wow you know it tastes so good
and that will make your day know you you
don't even care people pay for your food
or not but someone to say that this
tastes so great you know
i think i i can identify with that
feeling so for me the aspiration to
create
uh beautiful things uh is very very
important to me without someone nagging
at me you know oh you must do this you
must do that and all that but but to be
able to create i think this is also why
the reason that the price room uh
undertake a lot of projects for
non-profit organizations
um
we because for me
it is important to put bread on the
table we need to strike a balance but i
if i have to run a studio
doing only i know reports i would rather
kill myself you know or rather than be a
lawyer
because it is so uh
soul killing you know you'll kill your
soul if you keep on doing animal report
and i know some design companies i
wouldn't even call them studios some
design companies uh
they specialize in doing another report
i can't even
imagine that i mean that that would be
so uh scary i i do only one or two i
know report a year only for my regular
clients just more as a favor because i
know report is really not fun guys so i
choose to do uh you know to balance uh
of course we have some uh commercial
jobs and all that even in the commercial
jobs we try to give our best i always
give a sort of a twist to it but the
other fifty percent of the time we spend
a lot of time uh creating uh things for
non-profit organizations they they
usually don't have a lot of budget but a
lot of them are very open-minded and
allow us to do things that are very
creative i work with a lot of artists
you know uh others have no money but
they have good place so they will come
to me i say can you make my book can you
make my video box set can you make this
and that and they will always say 100
freehand to you kelly because we respect
the creative process just like because
they are also artists and they
understand how important it is so we do
a lot of work for digital artists
we do a lot of work for a dance company
theater companies uh etc you know for
posters books and all that and i i think
it is a really um uh that kind of um
the passion to do beautiful things and
also the empathy to be able to share
good design without um without judging
like who the client is and all that and
i think that to me
um is very important because i think
beauty is so powerful you know last time
during covet the papers say that uh
artist or art is the the most
unimportant uh
uh
uh profession you know during kobe and i
totally disagree with that
i think i think artists and designers we
have the power you know to create beauty
which which provides the purest and
simplest basic most basic form of
happiness to people
when you go to east coast and you watch
a sunrise or a sunset it's so beautiful
you know it's something that you you
feel so move and and
it's priceless you know and everybody
can enjoy it you look at you go to
buktenka gather you look at the trees
look at the butterflies and if you're so
happy in your heart it's free you know
and i hope that the press room here we
want to create works that provide people
with the same kind of enjoyment and
happiness without people having to pay
so people pick up a product design but i
said wow this is so beautiful and for
that moment you know the world stops
and you just provide that most simplest
form of beauty to people and i think
that is
priceless
so uh the other the other thing that uh
as i get a little bit older um i also
find that it's very important for me to
to find meaning in in what i do so uh as
i mentioned earlier yes i mean to be
realistic you need to do beautiful
things you need to make money you need
to balance both you see uh because you
have staff and all that you also want
them to be paid decently and all that
but for small studios to be honest we
cannot compare to the big advertising
firms and all that but but the in
exchange for that you know you can have
a much more meaningful career knowing
that you have created beautiful things
and for worthy causes
so anyway uh so as i as i go along and
i've been doing that uh and now as i'm
getting even a little bit older i i'm
just thinking how i can do more for the
community and i i think it's really
important for uh for us to keep the
design ecosystem you know the older
people to mentor the younger ones and
all that so that we can create a design
history and then a design culture can
evolve you know because if whatever that
we learn our experiences and all that uh
does not get passed on then uh we we
won't be able to complete this
ecosystem for our singapore design
community so uh in the recent years i
dedicated a lot of my time giving talks
like that giving talks to school
um mentoring young designers spending
more time teaching in school and and all
that and i find that
it gives a different meaning uh to my
work as a as a designer so i think that
is also uh
an important aspect
um okay so so along the same line uh
last year covet uh was was very it was a
struggle for most companies including us
um a lot of our jobs are tied to
marketing and events and they will all
stop
so uh we don't have a lot of things to
do so i started to think like what so
what can i what can i do you know
something that is meaningful uh during
this uh quiet period and um i decided to
do this project this archival and
documentation project called
um because i realized that a lot of our
uh first generation graphic designers
third generation architects uh and all
that they they are slowly building away
and passing on and we we don't know who
they are you know because sometimes when
i lecture i refer you know to some of
these architects or designers and and my
students all blur no blur face i got
very worried like huh how can you not
know these guys they are like the the
masters of singapore you know so uh it
triggered me to want to do this project
to document uh the stories and journeys
of singapore designers of all genres the
more i can document the the better it is
a self-initiated self-handled project we
support from design singapore which i'm
very grateful for um so last year we
spent the whole year building up on this
project
making this vision come true
and this will be a lifelong project for
me my commitment to the design community
and i will continue to do this until i
die yeah so uh we
uh like i said it's not an easy job so
uh whoever that wants to come and
volunteer and help us uh i welcome you
so get in touch with me
so anyway if you have time please check
out this website it's
www.studiosml.net you can check out all
the stories for free because in this day
and age i believe that content has to be
for free for people to want to access it
and we want to promote the design
industry we want to spread these stories
we also want the general public to
understand the hardships and the
struggles of designers so that hopefully
you know you will build the ecosystem
people are willing to pay designers more
and all that and the future generation
of designers will not have to struggle
so much like us today
okay so in relation to the sml website
uh uh design counselor has very kindly
offered me a space to build a teaser a
sort of a launch pad for the website so
i created an art installation called
abstract creatures uh the reason why i
call it abstract creatures because it's
a metaphor for design studios most of us
started designing because we are
passionate we just want to do design or
that we don't know how to do business
actually so uh but somehow we managed to
find our way in a very organic sort of
way so that's why i think every design
studio is like an abstract creature of
its own so uh i welcome all of you to
come and visit the exhibition at uh
national design center it will be on
until end october so
please come down and have a look and be
inspired and you can get free stickers
on site
okay so to end off my talk today uh i
just want to say um
don't get misled by the wrong reasons to
go into design um it is very important
to know where your heart is and what is
your reason for going to design and more
importantly if you start your own design
studio you must
uh have a higher expiration because uh
running a design studio is is very very
tough it's not easy
uh so you need um you really need to be
very convicted in uh what you want to do
and lastly um i just want to say that uh
in life um all of us not just designers
we need to create a nice equilibrium
because
um
you can't just be working all the time
no matter how passionate you are about
design you also cannot do 24 hours
design a day
you need to be inspired by different
things with gardening go to the museum
watch art and all these kind of things
in fact i always encourage my designers
to do that because that's that's what
inspired you you see everything in life
inspire you
and you should you should have a
work-life balance which i think a lot of
you younger generation
you know you do prioritize that which is
important so you know work very hard but
also have some interest on the site and
enjoy life learn how to relax learn how
to kind of separate when you're relaxing
uh and when you're working because at
the end of the day uh life cures your
work and what complements your life so
uh while you want to be a very good
designer you should also learn how to
live your own life with that i say thank
you
thank you kelly for sharing about your
dreams to create beautiful things and
your inspirational journey you have
certainly created much beauty through
your designs
our next speaker is ashley assaleem
creative director of kinetic singapore
ashrae is by her own account and
accidental designer who jumped into the
profession thinking all one needed to do
was draw she was pleasantly surprised
that design encompasses so much more and
has never looked back since
astrid's work has received international
recognition from the dnad awards khan's
lions awards the one show young guns
tokyo type directors club the singapore
creative circle awards and not
forgetting the president's design award
astrid over to you please
hi everyone thank you for joining the
session and thank you patient for the
introduction
uh
i'll share the screen for my
presentation
okay yeah
okay so uh
i'm astri and i'm a creative director in
united singapore creating singapore is a
fully independent creative agency and a
space champion of local talent we are 21
years old and
we are a small studio but we have proof
that our work
uh trump size and we put our little
record on a world map with over 500
awards and counting
so this is what patients say just now so
i joined inside industry by accident and
i'm pleasantly surprised that design
encompasses so much more and i ended the
president design award here
so how i started is as you guys probably
can tell i'm indonesian i'm studying i
studied in malaysia and upon graduating
i actually had a job offer in milwaukee
kl but my working visa got rejected so
upon this visa application i am three
months jobless but i at the same time i
needed to pay off my student loan asap
in indonesia the fresh grade designer
pay is around three to four hundred so
uh it will take me a very long time to
finish the student loan and singapore
dollar is better so
yeah that's a brilliant idea i need to
to land a job in singapore uh with my
background and the fact that i'm not
studying here i know that it's a
it's quite a far fetched for me to to
work here so i know i need to do
something different so i made a video
with my laptop webcam i
look for the plainest wall at my home
and i sit against it set up the camera
and then i introduce myself hi i'm
ashrie and i'm a
leader student looking for a job in
singapore
so then i
walk towards the camera and i
show my pants i pull down my zipper and
i actually wear a shot inside don't
worry but i changed my underwear to
pixelated area and i put a hovering typo
on top of it then it says i can do balsi
work hire me
and then i was a bit shy about it but
then i decided to send to four to five
agencies that i wanted to join and two
weeks later
i'm on a plane to singapore
so yeah thank you steve eric this is my
first ecb who accepted
my email and also offered me a job here
i then worked in my first agency for two
years but i felt the environment didn't
really switched me so i joined kinetic
in 2012.
a lot of things have happened and
yeah i'm still getting
sorry for the deck animation problem
so these are some of the projects that i
thought are bossy and some learnings
from them that i'd like to share with
you guys
so the first one is called mini vito you
drive with a unique go-kart feel driving
a mini is addictive which is why drivers
who test drive are more likely to buy
one but how do we get them to do a test
drive in the first place we decided to
target drivers in need when the cars
[Music]
we partnered with a tow service company
and responded to breakdown calls in real
time throughout singapore
[Music]
while tow trucks picked up the cars
drivers drove off to wherever they
needed to go
initially i was very shocked i thought
like it's something
that you have to pay for so when i knew
that
there was this game i thought it was
actually pretty good and very innovative
i think we told you drive is an
excellent experience and an idea because
especially people in distress and need
and you guys came to save the day i
think it was a wonderful experience
when i first sat on this uh meeting i
felt that wow it's really can fly the
speed the power uh the strongness the
strongness that uh we really can't
express ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as you can see we made people do test
drives without them knowing
to the other cars have a speedy recovery
[Music]
so yeah from this
uh we actually when we did the project
we actually been working for a minute
account for a few years and we feel kind
of stuck on like how do we do things
different again so uh we keep thinking
on like the sales point test drive on
how we connect to people on the social
channel eventually we realize oh there's
this another way when our competitor's
car break down so opportunities are
everywhere including in time of crisis
okay the next project that i'd like to
share is also for mini it's called mini
extraordinary
imagine ink made from sewage or plastic
that you can eat how about homes that
are grown from mushrooms
find them odd
mini extra ordinary an exploratory trail
as unconventional as the brand showing
how odd innovations may be key to a
sustainable future
to make the odd more palatable we fuse
them with familiar cultural icons in
chinatown
like the chinese guardian lions
traditionally cast in stone derived from
destructive mining ours were made from
mushroom mycelium instead grown to shape
in the land
stronger than concrete yet more eco this
mushroom cement may be the building
material of future homes
or have some herbal soup boiled together
with its plastic packaging made from
seaweed this edible plastic may yet end
plastic pollution in the ocean
for our calligraphy demonstration we had
the master write in sewage inc instead
of auspicious greetings the words urged
visitors towards zero waste
we warmed up people to the idea of
eating algae with algae fortune cookies
that showed the fortune of our earth
lies in their hands
live algae was also presented as the
protein of our future right next to
fishes in a seafood display like those
in chinese restaurants
no visit to chinatown would be complete
without trashy souvenirs which in this
case were really made from plastic trash
the same trash was used to build a
chinese chess table too
the trail and its 16 exhibits drew more
than 74 000 visitors over three days
many extraordinary because a dose of odd
could very well change our odds
yeah so for this mini extraordinary
project uh we are initially we're kind
of worried of using the new materials
after all we are dealing with mushrooms
algae melting plastic and also seaweed
so i remember me and my partner were
discussing and then we said uh yeah we
are very scared of doing this but if we
are scared and nervous on how to do it
the more we should do it and
when we have managed to
finally finish the project and we
managed to do it well uh it felt more
worthwhile so never afraid to bring the
future forward
okay so the next project is the not so
convenient store
convenience it's a big part of modern
life unfortunately so are its effects
2 billion tons of waste every year
mountains of plastic which take 1 000
years to break down more plastic than
fish in the seas by 2050
how can we get people to move away from
this culture of convenience
introducing the not so convenience store
probably the first convenience store to
promote inconvenience
reusable straws you have to wash instead
of throw travel tumblers that add weight
to your bag
capsules that take longer to prep and
clean
compost kits that require you to live
with wormy waste for months menstrual
cups that need to be emptied and cleaned
inconvenient zero waste alternatives
like these line the shelves of the store
the drinks bridge is full of bottles and
cups that can be reused while the
freezer is repurposed as a recycling bin
every product comes with a tag that
spells out the price of convenience as
paid by the earth
this is reinforced by other displays
at the cashier notes on how to live more
sustainably are put in the till to
inspire change
branding materials continue in the same
vein with playful twists on customer
service mottos
we enlisted sustainability champions and
influencers as employees of the month
serving as examples for others
we also created instagram stickers to
help spread the message on social media
turns out people loved being
inconvenienced
the not so convenient store was featured
on the news and multiple sites online
it also evolved into a mini movement
which saw people pledging their support
[Music]
you don't need to be a hero bring your
waist down to zero find out more at the
not so convenience store
okay so use design to do good things
with the nozzle convenience store we
presented the solutions in the engaging
way and it shows that with good insights
and we craft the design we can change
people's mindset so i think maybe like i
said i think an example of like the
recent trade regulation and if you don't
return your trade you can get five but
maybe instead of fine we can try like a
new campaign like called uh trey harder
you know like maybe but all i know is
with design we can present solutions to
solve the community problem and we can
contribute to do good things with it
okay so the last project that i'm going
to share is called thank you delivery
heroes
from groceries and essentials to sweet
cravings and more delivery workers bring
them all
there was a time when we would rush to
open the door for them
then came covert 19.
how do we show our gratitude to those
who stay out as we stay home
when the door is in the way
what if we turn the barrier into a
conduit of thanks
by using the door for thank you notes
[Music]
thank you delivery heroes
we created 24 posters for our delivery
heroes with thank you messages that
ranged from the heartfelt to the cheeky
the designs were put on our website and
everyone was invited to print them and
put them up
from one door to another the movement
spread
and in just a few days hundreds of doors
across the country joined in
even cafes and restaurants took part
no printer no problem
many got creative and made the posters
by hand
thank you delivery heroes soon became a
part of the national conversation on
covet 19 efforts the idea is simple
people can download the posters from the
website add on them as they like and
stick them on their doors
with the community's participation our
message of thanks was received by
delivery workers all over singapore
so while doors remain closed our little
initiative made sure that they are no
barrier to open hearts
okay so uh i always like to end my
presentation with the last point which
is the writing matters so when we first
started doing the thank you delivery
heroes it was at the start of the
of the covet and the circuit breaker and
then is
the first time is transit from working
physical to digital it's also the first
few projects that we work remotely but
yet it happened very seamlessly from
sharing ideas to the execution writing
the headline the poster designing all
the illustration and the type so yeah it
just happened very smooth and everyone
uh
contribute and support the ideas and to
receive the positive responses from
public it it was such a mood booster
from uh in the pandemic then uh yeah so
with this project it's also kind of
shown me how the culture in the company
matter and also like to give it to
kinetic team from the past and the
presence to where i am now i'm i'm such
a lucky person to be surrounded with
talented people with little ego and i
also have the best mental fun meme he's
the one who's holding the right safe
keep well so yeah i guess the last point
is we'll be doing this in the long run
and do it in the environment you can
drive in
thank you and if you want to know
more about the work that you do in
kinetic and how our culture is follow us
on the kinetic ig and we will have a new
contact videos coming up so yeah stay
tuned
thank you ashrie for your funny story
and how you started your career in
singapore and your insightful sharing on
your ballsy projects
next we are steve lawler co-founder and
head of creative of ayah together with
co-founder tanya wilson they created ir
an educational platform that uses visual
communications to nurture children's
creative and problem-solving skills
born in iran raised in hong kong and
educated in europe steve attended the
prestigious fabrica art residency in
italy his artistic work is an
exploration of trash pop culture
colliding with the old and historical
mixing media such as computer
programming digital sculpture painting
and printmaking
his works have also been regularly
featured around the world at
international institutions and
independent galleries steve over to you
please
hi everybody uh
thanks paige ryan thanks for saying that
because uh i hate saying that stuff
um
right so i'm just gonna go full screen
and just give me a sec um there we go
the unusual network this is like just a
cover slide of
where i am right now in my life and we
we work with artists and brands and do
all kinds of projects commercial and and
um cultural and i think
um i'm just gonna jump in and
show you my first slide which is me this
is me uh that's not my car i can't drive
but uh a very talented painter here
jabba painted that car for us in a for
an event we did years ago the sculpture
on the left on the right surrey is
probably my biggest achievement
literally it's about four meters high
melting superman um
uh in response to the idea of kind of
global warming and i and i just i think
like the point for putting this here was
like i started with a very
traditional graphic design
uh
entry point in brighton on the south
coast of england and
in the next few slides i'm going to just
show you how that has just
unraveled into doing many many things
outside of graphic design but but with
the same kind of thinking
so brighton is quite a strange surreal
place it's very colorful little town on
the south coast of england
a lot of creativity is born there a lot
of great music
and i was lucky enough to study graphic
design there in 1996 to 99 i met some of
the
craziest people back then and
we were also lucky that our our tutor
brought in a lot of practicing artists
from the industry and we were very
quickly kind of
able to familiar ourselves
familiarize ourselves with the industry
but while i was upright and one of the
um sort of
uh key things that happened is we used
to have a film teacher who took us sort
of every tuesday
and
i didn't realize but film was designed
and
i think this kind of opened um
this little thing in my head where
i these are names of directors who you
should know so maybe just take a
screenshot of this
page
and i love the idea that film can take
you backwards and forwards in time and
um
for me this was really an interesting
area to study
because i felt like conventional graphic
design
a lot of things had been done but when
you started to infuse ideas from film it
kind of unlocked a lot of potential for
me
now um
now i think
one of those main things and one of
those mains ideas was the idea of the
idea the concept so
style is important and style is
something that can be mimicked and and
you can practice things in a certain
style but unless uh you have a concept
it's kind of uh meaningless and if
you're not sure what a concept is the
concept is the message you're trying to
communicate i always grappled with that
early on in my career i was like what's
an idea what's the concept and it only
became clearer later on when it was like
what are you trying to say
um
with your with your work and so
translating your message into visual
formats
is aka visual
communication um
and i became really obsessed with this
idea of communicating with images
and so back in the 90s there's a famous
italian photographer called oliviero
tuscany
responsible for a lot of these um
uh provocative um
kind of constructed images to do with
uh in sort of human issues like war like
famine like uh racism and here's a
really great example
and so what i started to do was i was
like who's making this stuff
and i found out that there was a real
place called fabrica and they and this
was in italy and you basically it was
kind of like a creative school so i
applied to get there
and by some freak of nature chance i i
got in and um
and when i was there
i found out they were responsible for
this magazine called colors
and um
i don't know if any of you know about
this magazine but i think it within the
sort of creative community in the early
days this was a real driver for uh ideas
so for instance they'd have a an issue
about travel or smoking or or genetic um
modification and they they basically
work with photographers and writers from
around the world to
to kind of um
analyze a topic
and of course this became
what i thought was really interesting
was this global perspective and this
creation of a kind of visual language
and so
i kind of took that idea and i was like
what if it was instead of photographers
what if we invited illustrators and
graphic designers and because that was
like my domain
um i thought it would be really
interesting so um so that's what what uh
what i did i invited a lot of my artist
friends from around the world to
visualize trust
and
um i got a whole range of responses and
and it became such a fun exercise you
know all these artworks would come in
and
basically organize the exhibition about
this
um everyone did the artwork for free
everyone thought it was an exciting idea
and plus they were friends so
so i was able to kind of curate this
collection
i did the exhibition and the exhibition
was only for one day so it was a bit
like oh man that that should be around
for longer which triggered the thought
why don't we make it into a
a kind of magazine as well you know
taking the idea of colors but opening it
up to illustrators and designers and
this is this was a free publication i'm
not sure if any of you know it uh but it
was around for about 10 years in my old
company cult and um
and one of the ideas one of the one of
the things we did was we took a theme
and then we just asked artists who
wanted to be involved and it became a
really exciting project for us and then
of course that content rolled out into
exhibitions into installations
um and animations and
like for example
um
your birthday than any other day of the
year now i don't know why that is but i
found it like amazing and i just think
uh
educating
with illustration can be so powerful and
and and using the skills and the tricks
of of someone
with a visual kind of uh toolkit to use
it for these purposes which gave birth
to this idea of ayah um
using art to educate and and inspire and
so
um
this is why i'm here talking to you and
with the design uh
the president's design awards and i
think we're really pleased that
we got recognized for this because
essentially it still is a very
independent zine we do it for fun we do
it for free
and a lot of the artists
give us work and and there's a lot of
support within the ecosystem um
and uh and we also
about 6 000 new computer viruses are
created every month
so that was that was working with an
artist called yellow marshmallow ida
who's from singapore and she's wonderful
and if you don't know her work you
should try and find her um
i want to show you this this was i was
introduced to this uh when i was first
leaving art school
and it's the first things first
manifesto
and and why it's important is um
it's it's it's it's bringing up the idea
of uh graphic design for commercial use
and and graphic design for social use so
um
what i want to do is
um i'd love you to go and find this and
read this okay i've tried to just
highlight
um
some of the text that i think is
important which is basically
um
[Music]
sort of it sort of echoes what kelly
said and ash tree you know there's a lot
of glamour involved in the industry and
people making uh graphics to
support
um
existing kind of grown brands and and
create a very kind of materialistic
world and i think
that's fine and it plays a part but i
think we should also consider what
uh what other things we can do with our
skill sets so i've i've done a little
poll maybe paige ryan you want to bring
it up um
should um design be used to sell
products or to change mindsets now
i'm not going to judge you but uh you
can answer this it's there's a you can't
say both um
but what i really want you to do is just
to think about it because possibly you
haven't um encountered this question
before and and the real purpose of this
is just to um
you know
make you think about it um
so first things first this was
originally made in uh
in
1967 or 69 i think um but please do
google it and please know about it and
and it says we the undersigned so
there's a list of graphic designers from
um
the early days who are kind of some of
my my design heroes you know like bob
gill helen kitching um and names you
probably don't know but if you go and
find who signed that petition
you will find a wealth of amazing visual
uh designers and illustrators and things
like that so wow look there's a very uh
conscientious crowd here uh 94
believe that
uh designs for changing mindset so
that's cool i feel like we're passing
the bat onto some some good listeners
here
um i've only got a couple of minutes
left so what i'm gonna do is
go back to my presentation
um
what have i got okay
tips to find your voice what one of the
main ones is um things like you're doing
now attend conferences i know they're
expensive sometimes but
watch the watch the aftermath on um
youtube screenshot this slide because
i've got a feeling i'm going to get
kicked off the chat in a minute um
make sense go to exhibitions organize
exhibitions experiment on your own work
um arrange lunches with creative friends
or people that you don't know and and
try and bring people together
find your design heroes whenever you see
a cool piece of work try and find out
who made it all these brands have
creative directors go and find out who's
the creative director of nike you know
go and
dig a bit deeper then you start to know
your domain more and then of course look
outside your domain as well for
inspiration we don't want everything
homogenized and looking the same
you're young and wild don't let them
tame you
i think i'm going to leave it there i
had i had an extra video here um colors
news machine
just google it and watch it okay because
there's probably uh more time for you to
enjoy this on another time so again if
you just want to screenshot this
that's me i'm i'll talk to you in the in
the
wrap up later
thank you steve for sharing about your
creative journey that's span across the
globe
last but not least let us welcome larry
pay founder and creative director of and
larry larry began his design career at
men's folio singapore's first men's
magazine and over the years his work has
been internationally recognized with
awards from the likes of dnad one show
tokyo type directors club and singapore
creative circle awards in 2014 larry was
convert the president's design award for
designer of the year and in 2016 his
work for bine artisan was convert design
of the year larry over to you please
uh thanks
patient let me try to
set my slice first
okay
okay um
full screen right patient
yep full screen
i'll continue on my slide i think we
don't have much time so i'll make it
quick
uh i think this is not new i've said it
many times i'll start with my hero
um fabian baron
so i kind of like
looked at harper's bazaar when he was
designing back then and um i didn't know
what role this was but
i love fashion i love typography i don't
even know it's called typography
and it's like so beautiful and wow i was
drawn to his world and i buy nothing but
harper's bizarre i'll get my hands on my
friend's copy
so i
i digged out like what steve mentioned
earlier like who the hell is this guy
looked at the credit page and back then
i'm quite old we don't have that kind of
google or what have you
so we can only go around looking for
like who's this fabian baron and that's
how my world design began i wanted to be
like him you know
so yeah find your hero is very important
and in the business
um some sort of advice i have
listed throughout the slides
you gotta choose your allies carefully
not just your friends or who you work
with but
your client if you have a commercial
client
um because people suck you dry and you
get pissed off you get angry
and i always tell fellow creatives that
we i feel naked you know i work with
lingerie models but i feel more naked in
them
because
someone like a musician or an artist or
a designer you put a thing out there
you are you succumb to scrutiny is so
come to people saying oh thumbs up
thumbs down
so yeah you want to work with people who
appreciate you bringing to a higher
level like in this case um
um on the left is royster tan one of the
uh
famous film maker here
not many people know that we're actually
friends since
uh secondary school in fact we went to
the
first day we met together so that we can
go to the secondary school together
uh but we were both misfits in school
and we were looked down upon like all
these two artists
i don't think they're gonna survive when
they grow up you know so we we clicked
we bonded
until today i just finished his uh
the design for his new film called 24
welcome
430 and a couple of films and i never
once asked him how much you can pay me
so yeah
um on the right
standing on the shoulders of giant uh
you see pan you see chris lee and
jackson and what and this i think the
seven rings and we know we need ten
rings like xiang chi so yeah later on we
brought three more guys in
um
yeah so like chris lee was my from
asylum he was my first boss when i came
out of army
um
yeah he said well i'm full i couldn't
hire anybody else
but what the hell man just come in the
next day again i started working without
knowing how much i was paid
i only knew when i got my first paycheck
and
i just met him last week for a lunch
asking for some advice
yeah you know in chinese everything that
it's an i mean like
a day of
a teacher it becomes like a father for
life so it's kind of like a bit cheesy
but yeah i always look up to all these
people
so yeah i think choose your friends your
allies carefully in the clients they
work with
um i'm not gonna share any of our
projects because right from the start
i love this idea that good designs
disappear and i've been figuring out
from day one how the mail make me and
make the company's work disappear but
yet at the same time the essence of it
remains and the good that it delivers
remain for a long long time so anyway
that's kind of stick with progress but
um the one thing i really enjoyed was
our rebranding we took 2019 way after
our company's trip to tokyo
immediately we came back was a lock down
and we took the time to zoom to work
and we took the time to rebrand
ourselves you know through zoom
vocational meetups
and yeah i'm happy to say that uh this
is one of the slide where i just i when
i created the company's name and larry
is about putting a spotlight on anybody
or anything right in front of me
and yeah this year on this is the new
logo and i want to showcase this one
that is made by
my wonderful intern um ex intern who is
now the
design singapore scholar in tokyo
and so i pay him a little bit of money
to do a bit of animation and what have
you projects so that he can
you know do his otaku dream of i don't
know cosplay dressing
just kidding but yeah this is what he
did for us
oops he's not playing
nevermind i'll skip the video sorry
shannon
oh it's playing now
let's give you a brief what do you want
to do with it so he did this animation
like oh short and simple
so kudos to him
um and this is one of the things that
after 16 years in the business we
actually
codify this whole thing called this
design with sole purpose and it's
something i'm very proud of me and the
team that we have put it together where
um
you know people say purpose is very
important but we always talk about soul
and that that differentiates what you do
like for example an elevator music
versus someone like
richie sakamoto or bill evans and
billy eilish so
how do you codify so and in a way we put
it into the very simple uh seven
dimensions of course a lot more to it
but putting on a lay to lay man this is
what it means um this is a beautiful
illustration by um mortez this
illustrator
where you know it's about passion it's
about uniqueness about relevance it's
about people it's about ownability
sustainability and ethics
and we use this framework to um
filter out the people we want to work
with as well as looking at the projects
that we work with as brand consultants
increasingly like i mentioned a lot of
our work disappears
we don't create anything physical
anymore for example
um
like we work with the in-house creative
team we work with in-house creative
directors and marketing people social
media people we give guidelines we give
like the do's and the don'ts i want to
highlight a little bit about the don't
because
because in the work where we do
like early on some of the speakers
mentioned we deliver things we create
things we sell things and so on and so
forth but
i'm more interested in what you don't do
and a lot of times our work revolves
around that like oh let's do this let's
do that let's roll this out let's roll
that out but we always ask no no no why
do you want to roll this off why do you
want to do this why do you want to
create another thing
um
so yeah so a lot of this
kind of a lot of soul searching
um yeah we also developed something
called the soul search methodology as
well so anyway i'm not going to go too
deep into this um
this is my team we are surprisingly
still a very small team we grow
we contracted and but in the end these
are five of us that
who made all the magic you see or you
don't see behind the scene that's done
by celeste and a wonderful illustration
with our names from the ears
across to our faces
and my last word of advice
um
don't burn bridges
because you know in this creative world
in the business world there's a lot of
money there's ego at work
so unless someone cross the line that
you set otherwise
it's not worth it just we're in the
business of people
of course an environment and so on and
so forth but
you know there's nothing
worth burning the bridges or make you so
unhappy or make it do stupid things that
in the end you couldn't sleep at night
so
life is short you got to preserve your
life by sleeping more
and with that i end my presentation very
short one thank you if you want to
follow us
and larry.com and ed and larry handle so
for me i'm really kind of out of social
media for a long time so you can follow
my team's work here as well
thank you
thank you larry for sharing the soul
behind your design studio and your
sagely advice to designers out there
i'll now hand the time over to our
moderator felix for the q a section
audience if you have any questions
please post them in the q a function
felix is the co-founder and ceo of the
global mentorship platform amazing
design people list adp list
he is also a product designer and tech
entrepreneur on a mission to bring
equity to the world through purposeful
designs his focus spends across product
design and growth welcome to lakes and
the recipients
thank you so much patient hey everyone
nice to be here um and hope all of you
have enjoyed the presentation as much as
i had as well uh through the past 40
minutes
so we will have a around 30 minutes for
the moderation
where we can ask q a to the uh four
speakers here um and then obviously we
will have a chance you have a chance to
ask questions so if you have already
have any questions feel free to put it
on the q a chat
and i will be picking them up later as
well but before that i would like to
start off the the panel discussion with
some of the questions that i personally
noted um you know really curious about
some of the work that the four panelists
had done
but mainly you know uh really to dive
deeper into the industry in general
right and i think this is something that
uh all of you uh would appreciate more
uh at this stage of your career right
and and assuming that most is also just
starting out as well
all right uh so this question is for all
the all the mod
all the panelists um you know people
just jump in in no order um but the
first question that i'm really curious
about after hearing that uh you know
your stories and your learnings is how
has the pandemic impacted the design
projects that you've embarked on uh you
know today right whether it be a project
that has been ongoing during the
pandemic or even before that or during
the pandemic how has kobe 19 impacted
your projects
so far
uh okay maybe i'll just share a bit um i
think covet 19 has uh impacted
every business everyone globally one way
or another big or small
um so as uh i mean for us as a small
studio we were we were badly affected
too because uh as a design studio a lot
of our works are
related to marketing and events and then
last year during the circuit break
i think a lot of companies suddenly just
pull the plug on a lot of project no
because they can't they don't know when
the government is going to lift the
circuit break and
whatever so um
so it was a sudden shock you know i
think for for many i guess not just for
me but for us as well
so we were during the circuit break
suddenly really just stay home and [ __ ]
late so uh good and bad luck i mean for
me it was uh
i mean after getting over the shock of
like yeah no joke um
it became like a long needed break for
me because i think uh when before
before the covet
uh many of us uh just finally
work you know we work so hard though and
we never allow ourselves that kind of
break you know that we we are entitled
to actually you know so after 20 years
of working for the first time in my life
i took a proper break you know
of two months of doing nothing much at
all usually
so uh so yes work was very slow but i
think something good came out of it
which is why i i just i shared that i
started a self-initiated project to do
xml
so that's for me maybe uh you hear what
others have to say
thanks for sharing that kelly
anyone has anything else to add on that
point
all right
okay we will move on to the next
question um there is it's also regarding
the industry in general
you know i think four of you here
has a lot of experience way more than
myself uh you know decades of experience
and i'm just curious from the
perspective of visual communication
industry how has that changed since you
started and where do you think it will
be in the next five to ten years
larry do you want to kickstart this this
question
oh [ __ ] i wasn't thinking um
uh well sorry come again summarize the
question again so so how has the visual
communication industry changed since you
started and where do you think it will
be in the next five to ten years
but the quick run through my brain it's
it started off as simple as my journey
where oh it's beautiful you know let's
create
wonderful things out there
to you know in the 90s you have ideal
coming in until now you've got all this
talk about empathy
uh design thinking and whatever what
have you out there it has caught on and
everybody somehow know what this whole
thing is about and putting in a pudding
design or ability to do all these things
that think like a designer in the hands
of everyone out there
so
i feel that it's no longer about
um
what you put out there but like i said
it's about
um
what collectively how we should
put our ideas
forward for a better world i mean
in that sense i mean kind of cliche to
say that
but better work can be in many forms
right like um like how kinetic is doing
that's
a wonderful one way of doing it but some
people like making wonderful music you
know it's
to calm people during the pandemic or
during the stressful times you can't
brush it off and say that that's kind of
like small compared to those guys who
are doing bigger jobs out there so
yeah for us it's
i guess more and more
soul searching is required in a way like
we read about how china is doing right
now
of course i got different views on
different friends be from the european
side to china side to singapore as well
um but yeah i mean they're doing their
form of cleansing and um soul searching
so i feel that increasingly whether it's
peer pressure or not
that might become something that
um that we knee-jerk for a lot of
people including our industry but it's
like this pandemic wow you know you
gotta figure out this gotta figure out
that um so coming back to just now an
earlier question about our work um
it hasn't changed except the fact that
well we can't go down and measure stuff
look look at the location if we do a
like we have project where it's a
journey user journey mapping and you
know we cannot walk around
yep that's what we wanted
so these are technical things which i'm
not really concerned about right we can
we can measure it later on or whatever
using technology but again it's that
really think about like
will your ideas work
pre or post
and for us it didn't really
matter that much because we were already
just
trying to figure out something that we
can design for a long long time
um
of course the things that we designed
may not last that long but the ideas
behind it concept like what steve
mentioned behind what you want to
communicate should last a long time
if not forever
so i i'm very critical about what we put
out there or not put out there so that's
kind of why i feel the industry
might be kind of
developing in my opinion in at least in
my world
all right thank you so much for that
larry um this question yeah
i will just add on a bit about this uh
how it has changed
um
i i think in in terms of uh how
we work as designers i i believe for
most of us we would say that it hasn't
changed much except that the fees has
gone down
and uh why is this phenomenon like that
so there is a major disruption
right now in the world uh in the design
world globally because of platforms such
as fiverr artwork and guru
um
i think it is um
it's something that we all have to
tackle you know and the young
generations will have to face this kind
of uh competition
because in the past without all this
platform um
for any clients like if you want a
designer you have no choice you have to
go to a firm right you know a physical
film and then you ask them to do it but
now they have so many options you know
they go to fiverr upload they they pay
for fifty dollars they get a logo
hundred dollars or whatever they get
unlimited changes and all that it's very
bad it destroys the ecosystem in a lot
of countries including singapore because
uh a lot of potential clients they will
say uh like you you like just saying you
charge them you said i charge you ten
thousand dollars for alumdu and they
said huh oh what's so expensive i go
fiverr i pay fifty dollars why should i
pay ten thousand because the the bottom
line is that a lot of clients honestly
it's not their fault but they cannot
discern the difference between say a 50
logo and a 10 000 logo and why it comes
with it you know whether the
applications the style guy and so on and
so forth uh all they know is that oh
logo just one small thing like that
right um and they also don't care about
concept and all that so it's a very um
it's a very i think it's going to be a
challenge that uh that moving forward we
all have to face because singapore is
also becoming very very expensive so um
if you the bigger firms are already kind
of like trying to you know use uh
foreign manpower they set up branch
office in vietnam or in china or china
also not cheap now um so they set up
offices to kind of like uh even out the
the manpower course you see but for
small studios like uh like me and larry
we can't go and set up a branch there we
still have to hire local so the grads
every year come out they ask for more
and more money but the fees is going
down and down because clients are not
paying us so much
this ecosystem is honestly you ask me
very disrupted in recent years
so i don't really know what's the answer
for it i don't have the answer um but
i'm hoping which is why with uh
platforms such as xml and and other ir
and other kind of platforms that we can
slowly educate
it's going to be a long long process
educate the young generation advocate
the general public and all that of what
design means what design really is and
uh how difficult it is to do a good
design so hopefully through all this
uh
outreach platform you know we can we can
educate the public more so that in time
to come
we have more uh discerning clients we
have more uh uh clients who are able to
tell good and bad desire then maybe
hopefully we can we can build you know
uh the singapore ecosystem if not then
we are our young designers will be
fighting against five dollar ten dollar
designer is fiverr which is very very
bad yeah so this is i think the biggest
disruption from the days that we come up
without having to fight this
to this where now you know it's it just
there's no more boundaries really people
can hire designers from everywhere in
the world and there are a lot of other
countries also they train their own
designers and they are hungry you know
you'll do a logo for cheap they'll do a
lot of things for cheap but in their
country maybe
dollars is a lot of money you see and um
so um it's gonna be tougher
all right thanks for thanks for sharing
that kelly i think steve raised his hand
and steve do you have something to add
on
uh yeah possibly a more optimistic note
um
i think the digital landscape
basically there's more and more
designers there's more and more
creators there's more and more design
graduates so you're going to find
yourself
uh pitching against
a lot more peers and so what you need to
do is to invent your own roots and i
think things like designing
our virtual
um spaces creating
opportunities for design whether they're
for commercial use or cultural use
um creating in those spaces and so that
doesn't necessarily mean programming
because it's the same thought process of
architecture but in a virtual realm and
so if you can
start to think along those lines you're
going to create a lot of opportunities
to yourself because in five years time
there's there there's just gonna be
so much to experience and you can really
carve out
an area uh that doesn't exist yet and
let's say you are a um
i don't know let's say a fashion brand
you can create a virtual experience
where people go shopping inside and that
will have within the experience uh
really good design like product design
architecture graphic design interface
design
and and people are already getting into
that space i think it would just be
worthy of taking note of who's doing
what in the so-called metaverse but but
just think of them as online extensions
and they're getting richer and deeper
and and honestly there's going to be so
much work around
thank you so much for sharing that steve
and you know
on in in recent days you hear a lot
about this digital arts as well which is
something of a new avenue where
designers and artists can go in uh which
brings me to my next question uh
regarding you know design and art i
believe it's a question to
to uh steve and kelly right so uh kelly
and steve you have work and this is a
question from audience by the way
um so you have worked with artists and
for
with a lot of artists and for steve in
particular you have created artworks
like melting superman
where do you see the line between art
and design and is there
a line between
art and design
uh okay so i mean if you look at art in
the broad sense like there's there's
abstract art there's
there's dance there's music you know and
i think
sometimes they are trying to communicate
something and sometimes they are left
ambiguous and open to interpretation and
i think where design starts to take over
is when
um the art is trying to say something
and then you can kind of measure its
effectiveness in that sense in in terms
of like
uh whether people understand that
message or whether they get it um
it's it's kind of simple as that really
i i think it depends on um
how you look at it because uh if you do
if you do design
for fun you know at home you create your
own poster and all that
uh the line is indeed very blurred you
know it could it could be considered you
know digital art and all that
um but in
in the in the light that if you are
providing a service to a client who hire
you to do a design
uh then there's usually a very specific
brief uh that you have to meet you know
and there are things that you need to
achieve you know uh very real kpis and
all that uh this is where i think it
differs from uh art where usually you
are quite free to create you know
um and you don't really need to
uh
do it with uh with you know a client's
brief and all that you can you can
really do what you want so i think um
that is uh
more or less the difference
thanks for sharing that uh you know i
think i i really agree on the side of
like the the art and and and design
because one of the things is like design
is more science than art right that is
where you can express your own creative
freedom whereas design there is some
metrics to that there's a success uh
this question is for ashrae
there is a young designer actually
graphic designer who just graduated from
university last year and
she's finding it a little bit hard to
find her match in this field right a
finite place in this field of graphic
design so she would love to learn a
little bit more about
how
you are thinking about career or how one
could actually find their right fit
in their career and seems like the
question is directed to you perhaps she
should look up to you in terms of
career-wise so we'd love to learn a
little bit more okay
okay
uh thank you for the question so i think
for me uh not the best person to answer
this question because graphic design
for me is very wide and i kind of apply
my skills to
many disciplinary and i actually quite
enjoy it meaning i design books and uh i
design for digital and
space
and i think it's quite refreshing for me
to like every time
uh when i receive a different kind of
brief or like i want to i wanted to do
different things and then i explore in
that area so i guess
i'm still confused as well and my advice
is just to keep exploring
sounds good
yeah i would also encourage you to keep
exploring as someone who is also very
new in in korea as well i'm sure
everyone could say the same
um okay so one question that i think is
really relevant to everyone here
which i think uh anyone can jump in and
answer in no order um it's like you know
i think singapore is a very small market
and you know it's still a growing
growing space it's not too matured yet
um but are there any tips where we can
you know reach out to a wider market
beyond singapore and what are some of
the actionable steps that one can take
if they want to you know do work outside
of singapore yeah reach a wider audience
um
maybe i'll answer this question so i
think for us in kinetic how we reach to
the wider audience is by
uh using social and digital now nowadays
a lot of platforms and like a lot of
zoom arenas where we can connect with
different kind of artists and different
kind of audience
and uh now it's pretty exciting in this
industry that uh our visual
communication can go uh in a two ways
communication but at first time we just
like post our work or like go on tv and
create a pvc but now we can post it in
our ig channel then we can see how
people react to it and then we can
connect to them and chat with them just
by sending a dm
from the three of the other penalties
any things to add on to that side of
reaching audience outside of singapore
well online since the obvious thing i
mean
there's so many communities
of musicians and especially like
regional
um
you can
as a visual designer
enter the space of music and
offer your
sort of powers to create album covers or
to create visuals for
um music videos you can also identify
what music videos you like write to
those directors
build bridges overseas through the
internet i mean i i don't think anybody
really thinks of just being in singapore
and it's and it's kind of siloed i think
singapore thrives off its
nodes to other networks and it wouldn't
really be able to operate um
without those kind of influences or
exchanges and yes korea japan have find
friends and peers in those in those
places get on beat hands and start
chatting to
people whose work you like you know get
onto
uh twitter and start following artists
who are from other countries and and
you'll soon find lots of similarities
and
um
within within weeks you will have a uh
external network
gotcha thanks so much for that
i think one of the uh one of the other
platforms that uh young designers can
look into is also really to join more
competitions uh so
if without the kovit usually like uh
global competitions they will also have
a big award ceremony and all that and
those are very good places to network
you know you will meet a lot of
like-minded people and designers and
that's how you can start to do some kind
of collaboration and all that and then
um
you can you can you can kind of like
have a kind of outreach so um i think
a lot of these kind of conferences
competitions uh
design festivals uh like london design
festival is quite a good place also to
meet people so i think these are all
very good platforms for young designers
to go out there first of all to be
inspired and at the same time to to meet
like-minded designers
uh from other countries and that's
usually how you start to build relations
and network outside of the country
gotcha
thanks for that thanks for that kerry i
i completely agree there's a lot of
communities and events where um you can
go to and there's just a lot of
international exposure there one of the
last few questions that i picked out
from the audience which is really
interesting uh this question is from
felicia malaysia
she is an aspiring graphic designer who
initially came from a background of
animation and uh she intends to go to
the university but is struggling to make
her portfolio stand out in her
application i i guess you know it's not
just about university application but
in job as well so
do you have any tips to uh to how to on
how to find your voice and make your
work uh truly stand out amongst you know
all the thousands of designers and
artists out there
uh customize your application
you know to whatever company you're
applying to i think
that often works um
find out the name of your person you're
applying to and
um
push their buttons uh yeah it's it's
competitive and there's some very
innovative portfolios that
that land on my desk quite often
and the ones that stand out um
tend to be
uh less generic like something that a
corporate portfolio would go to ogilvy
or something like that so when
when it's
resonating with the the person you're
trying to
get a job from i think that might mean
making 20 different portfolios uh it's
just the way in the world unfortunately
i think uh just now ashley
gave her her own experience and advice
right like
pick up your pants but or do whatever
you want
yeah yeah go for it
yeah sorry yeah uh if i can have on
maybe for felicia to find out like
what's the story that you can tell about
uh yourself so that that can be your
cover letter and also of course
designing it well and i think uh
now that i'm in a in the other side of
the application right it's also about
the right timing so sometimes like it
can be a good portfolio but it's not the
right time so
uh
just keep sending to the places that you
want
well i have something
borrowed from um
you know
the the mr y i call him
the power of why so i think it's very
important to
be like what
it's very important to kind of
be very clear about why you do what you
do
and make that come across very
immediately instantly to whoever you're
applying like what steve said press the
right button
so if you know if you're gonna
attract a rock
rock star kind of a design company then
you better look like
you're about to
to start a rock concert right
so uh why you do what you do is very
important because increasingly even in
my job not just about students
application or whatever but even to
clients we're talking about some of them
are really
you know ultra high net worth people
when you ask them
strangely very few people can tell you
clearly succinctly what
why they do what they do you see so why
do you start this business what the hell
is going on
so when you start the
whatever they want to apply
it's that's very important for me
in my opinion
100 agree there larry one of the things
that i that i learned as well is the the
why
beyond the what you know like um people
people would often buy into your why
then then you're what you know just like
how um apple markets themselves and
people fall in love with the brand not
because of the things that they build
but just how they make you feel right
like and their why as well so thanks for
sharing that um okay last question for
all the panelists and obviously if you
could chime in um however short your
answer may be um
this question is by
a
the audience
and the question goes that uh may i know
what is your take uh on learning and
doing design overseas uh if an
international exposure is important for
young designers for example whether they
go going overseas for studies or um for
for any work uh you know
is that important for for young
designers is that a competitive
advantage as well
i might answer that um
i'm not sure
i think travel is pretty
key to creativity i think
um
you often find when you're overseas
you're looking at things through a
different lens
and
um
and sometimes when you come back you're
looking through
an alternative lens and and just the act
alone you know okay i'm not talking
about beach holiday uh maybe going to
taipei just for a sort of couple of well
five days and just seeing how things are
done differently and people's mindsets
and
um how they serve food and and all these
things and and the more you do that the
more open and broad-minded you become
and the more you can um
take on board new ideas and and and
weave them and bake them into your your
own
uh thinking and i think
i
it's kind of proven that travel breeds
creativity because of that reason
um i think definitely if uh if you have
the opportunity to uh study abroad or to
travel uh that that is great you know
because being a designer is not just
about working in your own silo you know
and
usually you actually get your
inspiration from a lot of things uh you
know
you go to art museums you go to dance
you go to theater you go to you read
books you watch movie and all that uh
it's so many things you see so uh
sometimes what we see here is different
from what you see from different
countries you see so it's about it's
always about building this uh
deep depository of imagery in mind so
that when you design you actually can
tap from this and then you can come up
with something that is that is of your
own but without this depository then you
when you design something you go to
pinterest then the tendency is that
you're going to copy
so i think uh opening up your eyes to go
and travel and all that is always very
good and also that just now in relation
to the earlier question that uh
someone asked like how to build network
you know a lot of your network is
actually also built from school days you
know um larry got to know no royston in
school and you know after so many years
they're still collaborating you know um
a lot of my classmates and and uh
friends from you know from secondary
school to anywhere that i'm still in
touch with uh some of them also become
my clients is it so they um
uh they also help you as you go along so
if you go abroad um immediately you know
your
your network your friends are a global
kind of thing and that that might give
you uh sort of uh a fast track you know
to building a more global kind of
network so one way or another um i mean
whether you study in singapore you study
abroad or that just make it work for you
and if you have the chance to go abroad
that's great
awesome
larry and ashley anything to add to this
final question
no i think they're all valid um but i
guess it's what i want to touch on maybe
it's about
local
you know globalization because
um
a lot of times sometimes you'll be like
i have a friend who
with france
you know study not in design and come
back and totally become like a
french
and then you start you know complaining
about things that like
you're a different person i don't know
you anymore what's going on
okay so i i feel that and that versus
like i always joke about ministers now
they're harvard different where they
come back they still sound like us
you know they still walk off the ground
like us so
i think it's about like
putting yourself
you we are all very unique so
having all these things
um
experiences and sharing and what have
you but you shouldn't change who you are
you should amplify it so i think
you got to know your
the root of who you are in that sense
so anything else is on top of it and you
know like a clay you just mold it and
make use of it i don't know when i'm
kind of still on point
so that is that is a very good point
thanks for sharing that thank you sorry
of course i was trying to answer
questions from the chat and trying to
listen so yeah
for sure yeah that is actually a very
valid point is the localization part uh
and especially about the ministers
that's 100 percent true did notice that
as well uh esther anything else to add
on maybe your friend from france maybe
in the house and later and poison you oh
i already made it like hey you know
what's going on man now you eat baguette
and whatever and you know
but i mean for me
um yesterday i was just in the
restaurant with a client right then as
an italian restaurant and i love
cappuccino and it's afternoon i freaking
asked for cappuccino and then that guy's
like oh no it's not cappuccino after 10.
you call me american call me singapore
whatever i want my cappuccino
i do that
all the time and i got slammed but
it's who i am
yeah that's
true okay actually you have something to
add right actually uh yeah so i i think
i just i agree with all the panelist
answers i think uh if you can study
abroad it's a luxury and you should do
it if you can but if you cannot then go
travel and if you still can't afford
that travel
trip go explore singapore because there
are actually quite a lot of things to be
inspired from here and also you can take
inspiration from people as well
movies and
other people's designs work yeah
awesome thank you all so much and for
the people watching this thank you all
for your question right uh three
takeaways that from here is obviously
the first one is to stand out you have
to be yourself have to put out your work
out there understand what truly makes
you different
and the other takeaway that i have is
the most recent question right now is
that international international
exposure is very important so
um you know you can go out there virtual
events uh communities and meet
international friends have calls as well
um you know have different perspective
right uh finally i think um that that
could help you you know create a lot of
things in design or in art whichever
that you're in yeah so thank you all so
much for for this amazing session and
thank you all for the four penalties for
being here with us today as well
thank you all thank you
thank you so much once again felix and
recipients
to our audience thank you for your
overwhelming interest and our sincere
apologies that we couldn't finish
answering all of your questions we will
try to answer all your questions in the
post event edm so please look out for
that over the next couple of days in the
meantime we'll appreciate it if you
could complete a short survey for this
webinar to help us improve on our future
programs please scan the qr code for the
survey form
share with us your greatest takeaway
from the webinar and you will send a
chance to win an exclusive pda2020
publication featuring the stories and
voices of our recipients and if you'd
like to find out more about the various
upcoming programs the national design
center has lineup do also scan the qr
code that you see on the screen and with
that we will be ending the session for
today thank you once again to all of our
speakers and to all of you for spending
your friday afternoon with us we look
forward to seeing you at our future
events have a good evening and weekend
ahead goodbye